this morning Iran is lashing out at
tighter economic sanctions being imposed
on it by the US and it warns it will
destroy anyone who attacks Iran in
reprisal for the attacks on Saudi oil
fields the u.s. blames Iran for striking
at those key Saudi oil facilities last
week Iran denies any involvement
Iran's threat comes as the US says it
will send military forces to Saudi
Arabia and the United Arab Emirates Ian
Lee is in the Saudi capital of Riyadh
with the latest Ian's good morning good
morning the US destroyer net C is
patrolling off the coast of Saudi Arabia
today it's armed with surface-to-air
missiles to plug the gaps in the
kingdom's defenses this comes as the
White House boost its military presence
in the region
Secretary of Defense Mark Esper
announced last night the u.s. is sending
additional troops to Saudi Arabian to
reinforce defences after last week's
attack on two oil refineries in response
to the kingdom's request the president
has approved the deployment of US forces
which will be defensive in nature and
primarily focused on air and missile
defense we will also work to accelerate
the delivery of military equipment to
the Kingdom of Saudi Arabia and the UAE
to enhance their ability to defend
themselves the administration says the
increased military presence will also
ensure the free flow of Commerce through
the Strait of Hormuz the critical
waterway where Ron has seized two
foreign tankers and allegedly attacked
several more in recent months the United
States and Saudi Arabia also accused
Iran of being behind the attack on the
kingdom's oil facilities acclaimed
Tehran denies this was the first look at
that damage with burnt-out towers and
storage tanks a devastating blow to the
heart of Saudi oil production caused by
cruise missiles and attack drones this
is a crucial part of the plant you have
the oil fields out there that oil is
pumped in through here to this part of
the facility this is where they separate
the gas and water from the oil and so
when the projectile hit this tank it
created an enormous fireball the fires
raged for hours and repairs are underway
but
pairing the calm in the region looks
difficult as tensions continue to rise a
beefed up US military presence on the
Arabian Peninsula has been a source for
anti-american sentiment in the past
Osama bin Laden used it to rally fellow
jihadis to resist what he called a
crusader invasion Dana
Ian Lee and Riyadh thank you in